sorry okay welcome back to the
obstruction committee
reconvened and uh the first item is
public forum and I welcome Mr Anton
Bayless
um please come up
and speak to us on public transport
um
is
all right yeah if you and Tom can come
and sit at the sorry
so that this table here
okay okay the way it works Anton is that
okay Anton try not to bang into it
Anton the way it works is that you have
10 minutes
uh assigned to you and you can use it
five minutes to talk to us and then have
five minutes worth of questions or
whichever way you want to use it so well
sure time is yours
okay thank you
um first of all thank you for the uh
opportunity to uh attend and speak to
you all
um I did submit uh
uh summary email in advance I'm not sure
if you've had the opportunity to read
that
um but just to recap
or just to set the context
um I am low vision a member of the New
Zealand blind and low vision Society
I moved to invercargill uh just under
three years ago
and I live in a what I call Little
Hamlet called inveruri
um just off uh Retreat road which is a
fairly new area
um used to be a chicken farm but it now
contains about 40 to 50 households in
that area
um
so there is a mixture of families and
elderly people in this area
um now to be honest and fair
um just about everyone in inveruri has a
car except me
um so I rely on taxis to get into town
um and I was looking at using the bus to
get into town but my research led me to
find that I had to walk 30 minutes to
um North Road to find my nearest bus
stop
which is fairly impractical for me being
low vision
so this sort of started me on a I'd like
to say a personal Crusade
but as I thought about it more
um I thought this is more
um relevant to other people in my area
and in the the greater area as well I
canvassed the neighborhood the Inverrary
neighborhood and I asked people if there
was a bus stop that was closer to our
neighborhood would you use it
um the responses that I received were
mainly from families that had teenage
children
um if the children
um missed the school bus home because of
after school activities or or practice
then
um either the parents have to go and
pick them up or they have to walk to the
public bus get the public bus and then
make the long 30-minute walk back to
home
um and saying that there were also a few
elderly people that currently do drive
but they're thinking that maybe in a few
years they may you know have to
surrender their license as I had to four
years ago
um and then you know they're looking at
relying on family friends taxis because
the the bus service isn't um isn't
practical for them
so that's um setting the context as I
thought about this more
um I started
thinking that maybe the bus service
needs a um a redesign or an addition
being and this is what a lot of cities
do in New Zealand Christchurch being one
of them it was having a loop service a
bus service that loops around the main
Avenues so an invercargill's case
I would suggest uh Thai Street D Street
bainfield Road and uh Queens Drive
um and a regular clockwise or
anti-clockwise bus service that
looped around
um the other benefit being there are
many businesses
um Community groups and schools
in that Loop so service those as well
and going one step further not getting
too carried away but looking to the
Future that this bus service could be
made
environmentally friendly either the
electric buses or biodiesel buses
um so yeah that is my submission I
suppose the immediate thought is having
a bus service
that is or a bus stop at least that is
on the corner of uh bainfield and queens
drives
um
yeah I'm not sure about the
practicalities of that but
that is sort of yeah the the reason I'm
here today I suppose
um okay thanks Anton um I'm going to
start with Darren and then Nobby and Tom
are you aware that there was a loop
service that went up Queen's Drive came
up to
Kildare Street to bainfield road because
actually getting any closer to the
bainfield Queens Drive intersection new
encountered traffic issues with the
roundabout
um but that it wasn't extensively used
uh yeah I was informed that
um a few months ago when I first raised
this and
the uh advice I was given is that there
used to be a bus stop in Kildare there
was a survey done a few years ago
which resulted that you're correct it
wasn't extensively used so that bus stop
or that service was taken away
um and the advice I was given was that
the closest bus stop to me was North
Road
and that that was from Council too that
advice
Mr Mayor Anton just just a bit of a
reflection from me I guess um
one of the things that we've looked at
is where we might do some joint ventures
in the future in relation to aged care
facilities
in part of that my you know stress May
involved some property that we own in
bainfield Road that's something we might
be looking at and if that were the case
there would be justification for a loot
bus that might extend past North Road
and come down bainfield and go back into
the city because there will be aged care
people that would want to use it so
we're not promising anything because
there's a lot of work to be done on that
yet but there is still some potential
there I think
further questions any money
yes Evelyn
I'm just I'm just curious
I like circular roads and we did used to
have them but I'm curious why you think
that only North invercargill qualifies
for one
um and I recognize that it's because you
live there
but
I'm reasonably confident that there are
aged
low vision
Etc people who live south of Tay Street
who might likewise do with that service
so just putting it out there
the
logistics that you're talking about
where you love the versus where there is
a bus stop
um must apply to others in that area as
well not necessarily an Inverrary
because if you look at Banfield Road as
a whole and the feeder streets that go
in there so have you looked at surveying
that area wider not just your Inverrary
area but the
um the Holloway streets all those
streets that also would have to go down
to North Road to catch the bus to see
just how much of a driver there is for
that sort of service I mean probably
really what I should be saying is that
he should do it but
um the staff behind me so I won't say
that
um but if the issue is how far it is for
a bus stop then it must apply to a
significant population area not just in
Ferrari it would be those
suburbs on the
um south side of bangfield road as well
and perhaps there's there's a bigger
need than we if we actually identified
absolutely yeah and this is really just
a case of starting small I suppose but
looking wider afield so yep no I take
that point
I wish I could say that we will solve
the problem for you and there will be a
bus tomorrow but sadly it's not within
my skill set
no and just to add as I mentioned this
started off as a personal selfish
Crusade I suppose from my point of view
and it sort of you know started sort of
drawing a larger picture
um from my own uh personal Viewpoint I
can use the Total Mobility card and
taxis which is easier for me than a bus
so I'm really here to bat for others I
suppose
time thank you right any other further
questions
um there isn't so thank you very much
Anton and I appreciate you coming in
um squeak your wheels always get oil so
thank you okay thank you
that takes us to the next thing we need
to do is receive a major laid item so
can I have someone move we may receive
the major Lane item strategic approach
to waste thank you Barry
and have a second to thanks Grant I'll
put that all in some flavor all right
we've done that okay that takes us on to
the minutes of the infrastructure
committee
6th of June
you know someone moved those thank you
Anya and seconded
second up seconded Leslie I put that all
those in favor
aye
that is carried and it moves us on to
the proposed right-of-way name
um
and does anyone on staff wish to speak
to that or
we received the port report
you wanna
[Applause]
welcome Patricia
Cura councilors this is a um
a standard right-of-way naming
um though I do want to just note that it
is not in 100 compliance with their
policy we are still encouraging
developers to think of Toreo names and
work with the turunaka in relation to
that but we are trying
um and that's we're all we're doing it
with best efforts of that at the moment
right any questions for Patricia yes Ria
um thank you Patricia I do noted that um
I felt that the policy that we have
around
um proposed names just didn't quite cut
the mustard here in that instance when
we've got
um
tour three
um con names as the council at all able
to put forward
a real name if we don't see one
we can but it's making sure that it's a
Rayo name is appropriate to both runaka
and it's having that list which we're
working with the runaka to create a list
of names that people could use
yeah we were looking at a list but we
also encourage people to look at the um
we also were encouraging people to look
at the area in which they were doing you
know these subdivisions were happening
and to do a bit of research into the
whakapapa themselves and we would assist
with to their own names if they found
something
that was relevant to that area
so supplementary to that thank you
um
I'm not obviously not monofinoa I'm
Masha Walker okay and sitting here I've
in my mind thought about
otatara and thought about the origins
and looked at a couple of potential
names that they could take for
consideration one of them being utter
hareke which is the flex Flex Lane the
other one and that's because relevantly
to their history
um there was massive Flex moons out
there amongs out there and it was a
thriving industry
and then the other consideration just
today which was I thought quite quick
um was the other
which is to do really because a goodwire
is similar of leadership and it's also
to care for our people and our
environment and when we look at odatara
and what we have out there in an
environmental areas is
um local native bushwalks trees plants
birds I mean they're relatively
quite straightforward potential names
for that
consideration that would meet our policy
that's
my views of putting something like that
forward
okay knobby yeah just some clarification
Michael or Patricia so this is not
necessarily a road change name it's a
right of way is there some difference
with that because my understanding is
the subdivision that's been proposed
here sits in front of the house of the
people that own it so the Campbells
stood up in 17 never if you know where
that is on the curve as you go around so
they've had a big space of land with
sort of run predominantly horses on so
they're obviously subdividing there so
it's not as though it's a sort of
traditional
you straighter really it's the existing
Road already runs to their house it's
just giving a name to it because they're
going to have some sections running off
that piece of that piece of driveway
which is what it is so there's some
difference between a right of way and a
um a more traditional Road
thank you through Mr chair and if
Patricia wants to answer I'm happy to so
the short answer is is no in terms of
the naming um walls it is considered the
same okay and that is reflected in the
fact that it will be called uh
such as that Oak Ridge Way as to
recognize that it is a private right
away that has been named for um
identification purposes as opposed to a
more formal Street in a bigger
subdivision like we've just heard about
and virari
um
but which then of course as a straight
vests and Council
so at this stage if if we are not happy
that at least one of the names and
errors not Torio
and just I'd like to understand the
process so does that mean that we go
back to say one of them must be to Rio
and then at the end of that exercise do
they still come back with Oak Ridge this
is the owners are we then saying that's
not acceptable it needs to be the tourio
so Council has the ultimate is the
ultimate decision maker on the name so
I've come to us to choose to take a
Tulare name yeah it would be entitled to
do so even if that was against the
developers wishes
um but if Council was to do that it
would be Obviously good practice for
staff to have the opportunity to advise
uh the developers that that was an
outcome that was being considered by
Council
okay thank you Darren
I guess it's just reflecting on on the
information that Michael's just given us
I see the desire to have a name as an
option but we haven't specifically put
that forward to developers and ask them
currently we have a policy you've got
something that meets the policy
and I think we're in a position where we
have to approve it but I think we should
also revisit the policy and and ask that
to be part of it so that way applicants
know that that's something that they
have to to consider as a way of process
Evelyn uh so
not that we're compared notes but I want
to support what Darren has said because
that was where I was going as well
um I had a conversation with councilor
Bond earlier and
that sits Within aotakiwa the names that
she put forward are not inappropriate
for the area however not necessarily
appropriate for this particular
situation and I'm not going to you know
I think hurts
um
desirable to have some Alternatives that
are not continuing
um
the past trends of necessarily wiping
our stories off the face of the Earth
but at the same time I think this is
actually quite a discreet
piece of space
um and
I understand the logic that has been
applied by the
um by the owners who are proposing this
I think Darren's point about the policy
and subdivision
is a good one in that we should be
encouraging those people subdividing to
look wider than their personal history
with the place and look at the widest
story of the place in which case the
issue of flax Mills or or whatever may
have come up
that's that's a different analysis and I
think
from my perspective as I've been looking
at this whole providing of material
names is that I would rather do it on a
case-by-case basis rather than people
select something from a list and try and
apply it to a place that's inappropriate
for example having something that is to
do with
um inland
so ammonia or something like that and
try and put it on the side of the
Estuary because that's that's not what
we're that's not where we would be going
so I think in in total I'm not opposed
to this I don't think it's a buggy but I
do like the thought processes that
councilor bond has put behind her
drawing attention to the fact that by
saying how to Keke you're using it to a
context that people understand which is
flax by using the word utter which is
another way for a a way finding a
footpath or a not a foot path a laneway
or things like that
um we could use hohanui as a road
instead of
something around the road it would be
achieving those sorts of things as well
it's a bigger conversation but I've
moved away from the idea of having a
list of names can I just say that sorry
Patricia
um because I think that that has a not a
potential for abuse as well so but it's
a thought-provoking conversation and I'm
glad we're having it and I think
councilor bond for her um initiative and
bringing it forward
thank you uh we have Leslie then Alex
[Music]
the first time we've been in this
position since we've instituted the
policy where we did ask
um
or preference that attario name the at
least considered and those that was put
forward
um
and
I feel it's quite
appropriate to express disappointment
that once again that hasn't happened and
I agree with councilor ludlow's idea
that we look again at this policy
obviously just saying
we'd like to see a trio name hasn't
necessarily meant that that not just
this developer but others haven't looked
into it and I do just reflect in this
case and while I agree with Reverend
cook that you know we can accept Oak
Ridge but the Oak Ridge reference goes
back to 2001. my feeling on this
particular
otatara area
is that
the history the exploration could have
gone back a great deal further
um and and found a more appropriate name
that actually probably fitted better
with a lot of the other names of
surrounding areas
um with with a little bit more research
so yeah I I just expressed
disappointment that once again we're
faced with no acknowledgment that we
have indicated we would like to see to
Rio names in the choices and perhaps it
is time we looked at the policy again
okay Alex
um thank you um I'm just I've just had a
look at um
Apple Maps um
around the area and I think on
reflection of what the proposed in the
scheme plan I just really wanted to
clarify which part they're cutting off
nibbon road at because it appears that
that entire driveway past the first
house on the in the initial lot that
where if it's cutting it off and that
was all being proposed to being turned
into Oak Ridge Way it's already listed
as nibbon road if we double triple
checked that that's not actually a
current standing road that we're trying
to rename yeah and and is that and
therefore is that person there in the
front house okay with their address
being changed
I have to um come back to you on that
one counselor because they're like and
they connect to Niven Road as well right
there so would and if their access then
wouldn't then would then be coming off
Oak Ridge Way
are they happy do they need to be
consulted and whether or not the street
name would be changed how's that going
to work it would be consultation yeah so
then are we are we sure that that's been
confirmed it's normally done we will
work at that between yes
the cat in the bag but yeah I've just
noticed that the whole road is Niven
Road right up to the
um
up to number 17 so if that's already a
pre-existing road we can't go here to
renaming it and giving it away
so can we do that please we'll check
whether that would be unusual for that
to be legal Road up there
yeah so like where does wheat is the
legal Road end is yeah
would be whether it's just a driveway
yeah it's driveway I think it's driveway
yeah
the legal Road will stop it then just
stops there it stops at the stops of the
road at the road
it's actually a big barrier there stops
at the end yep okay
um excuse me look I've done the rural
run there there are three houses on
Niven Road the the renaming's part of
the driveway that goes into the house at
the very back which is owned by the
Campbells so it took quite a long road
but it is what you'd call at the moment
a driveway private driveway goes past
paddocks into the house at the very top
on the ridge
so that's I guess where the sub version
is going to go and that's where they
want the rename it yeah okay thank you
Tom no no sorry that's not that wasn't
handled for
look I just I'm a bit nervous about
where we're going on all this
um who Darren say that we should revisit
the policy and I agree but we'll need to
consider some very sensitive issues
around this so if we want to increase to
Rio names in the city
and this is a good example if we were to
insert a name into it then are we get
doing that for the benefit of getting
the owner of the sub version to adopt
the Terio name in good faith or are we
saying we're putting in so that we've
got an option that we can mandatorily do
that and if that's our push going
forward for the next 10 subdivisions to
have two real names which is this what
the policy needs to say then it needs to
say that so that people don't get
excited about having their own family or
historical names and they're only
defined we override them and so that
policy will need to cover that off and I
think that will be a very sensitive
issue when you start doing it because
the history of invercarl from what I can
see has been that the developers are
allowed to
allowed to have family names or family
history involved and we will be taking
that away if we do
but
okay Tom all right my question is would
we need to consult on that an alteration
of that magnitude
I'd have to take advice from Rhiannon
but we may have to yeah
because changing but whether it's
considered to be just as minor change
and we wouldn't we would try and time it
was something else that we were doing so
we wouldn't be doing an independent
consultation with that alone if we had
to Tom
um so since
the beginning of this trainium
I think we've had
several four or five
um streets to name
um I don't recall ever there being a
terio name proposed
so I I and yeah I know the policy which
are support
so I put myself in the shoes of the
developer
and not only to the extent a little bit
not only are they asked to include a
today or option
but picking up an Evelyn's point it
needs to be irrelevant to real option
it's not just kakapur 2 or something
it's going to be irrelevant
that must be quite difficult actually
and and I wonder whether
um we just need to provide them with
more guidance if we don't provide them
with our list and understand everyone's
point if we don't provide them on the
list there has to be a process by which
they can bring forward ethereal name
which is relevant to that area and
whether that's they have a contact to
or something I don't know but but if I
was a developer I would have no idea
unless it was two year kakapo or
something which we don't want 50 of
those so
um yeah yeah the point is let's develop
a process let's give the developer a
letter that says this is what you do you
must bring forward a to-do option and
here's how you arrive at that auction
because otherwise you're never going to
get one yeah
um unless it's a developers himself just
to question Patricia if the road
is privately maintained and not doesn't
come under Council
jurisdiction on on that aspect does this
policy apply to that
if it's privately maintained at the cost
of the residence
I think it still does yeah and Michael's
nodding in front so they they're paying
for a road because it's an
identification yeah for that property
for emergency services for yeah that I
think it definitely needs consultation
on in that case then because if you're
funding our the cost of a road I think
there needs to be um Universal
acceptance of names any more questions
or comments regarding this otherwise
we'll move straight to the
recommendations
and they are to receive the report
and recommend to counsel that the
proposed right of way be named Oak Ridge
Way can I have someone move there please
Grant seconded Peter put emotional as in
favor
scary thank you
now can we just go and check
to the
same necessary it wouldn't have come
here if it didn't no well Patricia
doesn't seem absolutely
Patricia how
do you feel yeah that the report has
covered any anomalies that Alex raised
or
do you want us to the risk of us
actually the right Council
okay the recommendation is going to
council which is there a meeting this
month the council meeting next week John
right
it's time seven days seven days we've
got to
do that
okay
so we're stopping around are we taking
names away are we no sorry
art system
thank you Mr chair
um
this is a small parcel of land uh
outside of 11 Catherine Street it's an
historic
parcel of land that Parcels of land
beside it appeared to have already been
a human stopped and
Amalgamated into the title
um this property was recently purchased
um in the new owners have applied to
stop that hustle of land outside
the boundary and Amalgamated two theirs
they're obviously significantly
considering it part of these with the
encroachments they're in there and
Associated will be met by
including the purchase of the land
are there any yeah questions yes Alan
just a quick question it just looks like
it's actually already part of this
section yeah yeah yes I do really it's
just a
I mean how come if it's a part of an old
road that does not fits on both sides I
suspect when it was originally
um
surveyed the ride was significant
significantly wider
and then the road has been developed so
all the neighbors must have done the
same thing yes
further questions it's just a bit of
anomaly Alex do they just pay market
rate for the additional slice of
paradise yes
somebody
[Music]
I recognize that because they've drawn
it to our attention and they want it to
be stopped as the road they're going to
have to
think it seems
sort of slightly
um wrong that we're charging them for
something that everybody else got for
nothing
um because because they didn't ask and
they've just you know how long has this
been going on I can't guarantee that the
other landowners got it for nothing
um we've had to stop Parcels of the road
and amalgamate them with the titles at
the same time so
um I I can't comment on what's happened
in the past
stretches quite a well-established
street that sort of puzzles me that
um
this could have gone on for so long it's
it was
well inhabited when when I was a child
um so that's we're talking about 70
years or so
uh where there's been housing that have
occupied those spaces it just seems
really strange that there's just this
one that's been caught up like that
right before that we know of yeah before
I before I continue just to hear that
can you answer when the people buy these
properties their lawyers see the actual
deeds and they know straight away that
this is part of the potentially this
came to the purchases attention through
a land information memorandum where they
noted that the boundary of their
property was actually so every property
purchase would have done done due
diligence and if if you don't might be
where so I have Leslie next
thank you I was just going to say
exactly that that this almost certainly
occurred during due diligence and
without doing quite a bit of historic
research we don't know for sure that
this has not happened at all both sides
of this parcel already for others
because it's it was an uninformed road
so it would obviously have been the
length of Catherine Street
um so I suspect it has happened before
and it would be a very time consuming
bit of historical research to ask our
staff to look at
how many of the other owners of the
kitchen Street had already gone through
this process but I suggest there's been
quite a few because it would have been
discovered during due diligence the
purchase of the property so it just
seems to me a very practical
solution here
um obviously we can't until we've done
the number three commencement of the
consultation we can't
um
say who's going to end up being the
purchaser but it would seem a very
practical matter to
to deal with this anomaly that appears
to be the last bit of Catherine Street
that has left this way and it may be
that at some time in the past boundary
pigs have been moved and that people
assumed it was part of their property
anyway and due diligence has discovered
it which is exactly what might have
happened with other properties on both
sides
yeah very how far does this actually go
back does it just go back to the back of
their boundary or this is the um it's
just that little parcel that you see on
the aerial
so the street is in front
and then yeah yeah that's what they're
after and their houses behind that yeah
okay we have uh Alan then Tom
oh I think it should um be taken into
account the fact that these people have
always been looking after this and I
thought it was their own for the last 70
years I'm not saying that those people
have been there for 70 years that are
there now but as you can see it's got
the concrete Drive runs over it and
it is also important that forms about
three quarters of the frontal loan with
um well established trees and things so
I'd be thinking it'll be sort of almost
a
just a
just to transfer our ownership in my
view it's
what do you so we still have to go
through the cons the whole public
notification process
and uh do the um the survey process so
there are costs associated it's whether
Council as part of that wish for them to
purchase the land as well as part of
that cost
okay um Tom you uh the last this has
been quite a lengthy discussion
when you look at the map and I'd just
mean this
large skill map I mean you look at a map
of casting Street obviously all of the
houses and outside of the streets set in
the same alignment
so you would think that all of them
either it would apply all of them this
issue or this has just been a simple
mistake it's some point in the past
probably by us again I without doing a
lot of research I wouldn't be able to
determine him no but but my question is
is this the only part of this still
shawna's Road are this Hall of Catherine
Street which it must be half a mile I
haven't I haven't researched the balance
of Catherine Street but within that
block this is the only one in their blog
so I I mean it's certainly through
YouTube I mean I was just wondering if
this is just a straight Mistake by
council at some point in the the distant
past in which case you know should we
really expected isn't to
through the course
just fix it sorry again I'm kind of
Mike's gonna sorry I'm thank you Mr
chair
to continue this will be something that
has affected at least this section of
Catherine Street if you look at the
diagram you can see the neighboring
property also has white lines which
indicates that at some stage that was
road that has been surrendered and given
its own lot as part of that record of
title for that property whereas if you
go to the left you'll see that there is
no white line which means that that hair
that road has been incorporated into
that piece of record of title to her own
amalgamation process Christine North
would have told me of I've got the term
wrong for that technically but it's
essentially what it's done so it is
something that has happened
um and it's just been something I think
that has everyone has said over the
forces of time uh people have lost the
fact that this was legal Road and you
see a nice boom and people have planted
it and as everyone else has it it's a
limb issue but it is something that
happens from time to time and when
Council gets abort to our attention it
is something that comes through to be
addressed uh road stopping there's one
way there's another one just for your
information and not to take up too much
time there's a building line restriction
as well that was applied on a number of
properties that had a similar sort of
effect to
but take the road in case uh Council
wanted to wait in the road 40 of a
reason
that was another mechanism that was used
rather than Simply Having a large road
so hopefully that helps with some of the
history
okay right that is it
um Grant you'd like to move these three
recommendations can I have a second uh
please thank you Leslie I'll put those
three recommendations all those in favor
aye
against the carried thank you thank you
takes us to the city activation plan
is the activator
thank you Mr chair uh take this report
has read this uh it's just a for
information update in support of the
following paper which is proposing three
road closures to enable the city center
activation of implant to occur have you
take any questions
okay so does this include tab nine the
road closures
uh what you're speaking to I I'm only
speaking to the dreams and sparkles
we've got pumps and pipes to come behind
me
[Laughter]
right any questions
all I can say to them
any any questions for Steve yes Evelyn
um so
I'm just a little puzzled why
um
we're looking at Don Street kosher when
it's a two-way Road when one of the
purposes of East Street was that it was
a one-way Street well this is actually
not the right I know but but the the
event the activation is to take place in
Don Street and I just that's my question
why did we look at Don Street as an
activator space when I thought that that
was part of the discussion about East
Street I'm not opposed
totally but it is a slightly more
complicated thing than my mind because
it's a two-way street and
um it affects also
um
you know a wider range of activities so
when these events came
to us
were they initiated by us or they've
been initiated by others so you've got a
few questions in there I can answer the
Don Street one because there's a liquor
license that applies to it and the
without venturing an opinion on whether
it's approved or not the holders of the
liquor license are in Dawn Street
[Music]
okay Steve yeah and look it's a it's a
valid question when you look at the
development of both Don Street and
District they have been done uh with the
mind to being able to be activated for
events and the rating basis is subject
to the targeted rate and this is and the
activation program is funded through
that targeted rate so we are looking at
CBD activation not just focused on East
Street
Alex Steve said what I was going to so
thank you
yeah look it's good to see something's
happening and there's a bit of planning
I think this is a test and learn thing
so I think we should support it see how
it goes get some good feedback and work
out
you know if
if it um
generates what we're trying to do
no bit okay just to reinforce that um
when we first set up the uh The Joint
Street's domain is there was the need
for Don to be able to be in the
entertainment area as well
um and it's got much greater capacity
than the ESC has got very much
restrictions on where you can put a
stage fragmentation very limited we're
down to much wider Street and has much
better capacity if you wanted to have
bands and things playing in here so
both have options no I'm not going to
talk to you anymore
history has a stage right okay so any
more questions for Steve on the
activations
nope and that in that case uh we just
have to receive the report yeah you'll
move that secondary
all those in favor
I can't be very sorry
you can't you're not on this committee
Leslie thank you it's done now we go to
Temporary road closures
can I just ask about page 27th Street
page 27. so in the last report
Mark Street one
see here it's down as Dawn Street I
think that's a talk about business can
we can we change that before we get a
speaker
okay that's page 22 which was the last
report specifically said the 8th of
September event was esque Street Night
Market
yes now saying we're going to approve a
temporary closure on Don Street yeah but
in the previous paper it says East
Street not Market that's what I'm saying
yeah this one says Don's yeah yeah so it
needs to be able to comment on that is
it the is it the street night market
and the is actually two of them is one
of the reports has got a
uh
is the correct one
um that's the that's the formal
application paper there might be a typo
in my report I'll take that
it says night food market on East time
and Friday 8th of September esque so
it's repeating your sister yeah the
previous one was Don Street anyway so
oh yeah
but then we have two of it so we are
talking Don street so there's two events
yeah and I think it is just a typo in
the first one so one's very strict one's
for Dawn Street if you look at the dates
one's the eighth September one's the
10th of November East streets 8th of
September yeah Dawn Street's 10th of
November so I think and what I'm saying
the road closures
yeah yeah I know but it should say yes
in the 8th of September one well before
we start personal resolutions
clarify it before we get to the
resolutions or the presentation because
if we approve the wrong road closure
we're not Mr chair if we could uh let
Aaron and her team get that assorted
we'll just need to move on to the next
paper okay we're gonna and we'll come
back to that thank you Leslie we don't
want to Chisel anything in stone
are there any risks for us leaving it
because I'm mindful that
yeah look I I think there's no typo in
the first paper I think that if you look
there are monthly gaps and I have pushed
um Great South to have a monthly event
so I the way I read that is we've got a
a woman's uh World Cup in August one
month later and
September we've got a food market on esk
and then a month later we've got another
Food Market on November on Dawn
just after clarification here yeah no
sorry I'm just following on from what
yeah you said I think we need to be
careful in instructing Great South
because it's provided the events conform
and I'll I'll use the example of one
that has a liquor licensing application
for it and we can't
guarantee that that's going to happen
until all criteria I mean
no don't don't get me wrong I'm awesome
can we just hey uh Steve do you reckon
we'll be able to get an answer 10
minutes
okay we will so we're gonna move on
we're going to move on to
CCTV upgrade that's great who is
speaking
Aaron welcome Aaron
thank you chair
um Russell Pearson um is currently on
annual leave and would normally be
speaking to this report but um
I had definitely um got the clear
message that elected members were Keen
for an update on this one as soon as
possible so I didn't want to defer to
the next meeting
um so as requested we've brought forward
the report which provides the timings
around delivery of the project you'll
see I'll just draw your attention to the
fact that we're running two streams of
this work somewhat overlapping around
the network design as well as the the
delivery aspects of the project
um there is some amount of risk related
to that but we do believe that it's
manageable
and is required for us to be able to
meet those deadlines that council is
seeking by the end of the year
happy to take any questions right I'll
open up for questions
not me
um Aaron the issue is around the traffic
management when we close the streets off
we raised this last time when um we had
the Fire display down their street and
the cost we're talking about CCTV oh
sorry yeah sorry we jumped because we're
waiting to get confirmation on the Don
isk sorry yeah it's okay right Leslie oh
sorry listen go from uh Leslie my
comment was just that the target has had
as many cameras installed and running by
Christmas 2023 as we can and and I think
we're all around the table Keen that
that happens so it's good to see that
the progress is going to make that a
reality
okay come on yeah um
firstly thanks for coming through and
it's good to see some dates written down
um the thing I got reading this paper
is you know what what are we trying to
achieve here in in that I think has a
should have a significant driver to how
we deliver and what I mean by that is
how much involvement has there been with
um the police in actual specification of
watch areas come you know first of them
so forth
um
because I think there's an element of
you know part of the community safe
thing is preventative crime and if I
talk to the police what they are saying
they need is the ability to monitor
ulterior routes because that's how they
can trigger that there's criminal
activity
going to happen particularly around
drugs and those sorts of things
so that becomes a higher priority than
perhaps
some of the things he is so the question
I've got is what is the involvement of
the police annexes Aaron do you come in
on that interaction um I actually wasn't
involved in those early workshops but
some people around the table were who
may be better to speak directly Leslie
was on the committee Leslie do you want
to I am the remaining counselor who was
on the committee and
he and well
been
put quite solidly throughout the process
because the lead person from the police
is actually no longer working for the
police
so my understanding from the police is
there's no one currently in the police
force here that has actually got
responsibility for this
well I can I can certainly tell you at
the time that the committee
met on the CCTV
meta the police were represented by a
senior police officer yeah and and that
person was giving the comment that we
also had representation from the
community Patrol
um we had no orders for Murray wardens
they were all very much on the same page
about the progress and and what we
wanted to see happening and the Order of
it happening yes so I'd be surprised if
the if the police were now to say that
um
there was that there was a problem with
the progress that's being suggested well
the conversations I've had with the
police in the last week says that
they're not fully aware of the exact
role that plan in terms of those
specifications okay look I think I think
wins wins Russell back uh for when you
leave a couple of months
tomorrow okay so what I can do is Cheer
I can talk to Russell we can liaise with
the
um
place
which is a good catch up because I'd
like to actually have a bit of a chat as
well this chair to find out and and we
can
absolutely Evelyn
um
which here I don't want to ask to lose
sight of one of the triggering events
that actually drew our attention to the
fact of how bad our CCTV was
as the murder in Don Street of a young
person which even though there was a
camera
was not able to service so whilst the
police have talked heavily about the
crime prevention of drugs and other
illegal activities that use that the
arterial roads they're really really
mindful that the things that go on in
the CBD
are a huge source of workload for them
at times so I don't see that they would
have a concern about the order of
priority that is within this uh document
and I would hate to see us slow at any
point we've had a lot of feedback from
from businesses from Individual people
and all those sorts of things but I
don't want it to ever be forgotten
that we
a young person died on Don Street and we
not not individually but we as a city
did not have good resources to help
identify
who did that as quickly as we could have
because our CCTV was not up to scratch
so
for me there's an element of personal in
this but I also think that as a council
we've said that we're going to do it
we've got a timeline I don't think
change of personnel sitting at the table
should slow us down at all not me now
I'm across the ball with the original uh
stuff when we first started this journey
um and just to reinforce what Evelyn
said
um the the main driver was the CBD to
start with and Public Safety and uh and
businesses feelings are they um they
were unsafe
um the policing jumped in with arterial
roads because they want the license
plate recognition so that they can
monitor criminal activities coming and
going and going is important as well and
so we've taken a state's approach I
guess there's two other things that have
crept in more recent times looks like
evidence here shouldn't slow us up but
it needs to be recognized Emergency
Management Southland have an interest in
CCTV Network that we're developing so
that as they get a disaster they can
monitor what's going on around the
streets very very quickly
and where hot spots might be that they
can't get past and the last issue is the
issue of hot spots so you know do we
have a camera on Steve Street Wharf do
we have a couple of
cars being taken out there and burned on
the beach and stuff like that so um
I guess that's the priority for me is to
start there and just work your way out
the hot spots would be getting towards
the end of that line and if we build the
network we can't do it all on day one
but we certainly need to do it in the
CBD South City love not Windsor
um
okay well Grant it's not risky so I
suppose the point is you know what I
want to absolutely ensure is the rollout
gives us the best protection I hear you
point Evelyn I've had that feedback as
well gives us the best protection as
quickly as possible for our community be
it around catching criminals that
already committed crime or preventing
crime that may be going to happen and
drugs and that sort of thing and that's
what I want Assurance for it happens
quickly and we achieve the outcomes for
Community as fast as possible yeah no I
totally agree and you've got to realize
that that the implementation of the
insulation is two part because the
number plate cameras
and not the cameras that are going to
catch
so the balance has come from the the the
wide view cameras that see everything
and then the number plate cameras uh
just focused on where the the traffic
goes so we need to actually speak or
have an update proper lease which are
the key uh roads they want to monitor
because you don't want to be wasting
those cameras but a complete coverage uh
haven't they fit that in to all this yes
and and there are if if counselors
remember there were very detailed maps
available with the staging and the
number of cameras and we looked at that
carefully from the point of view of
staging to get the best being for the
available funding in the quickest
possible time what I'm trying to say is
that I'm making sure that they're aware
of The View
that that camera is going to give them
and they don't expect
more than that particular Road View and
then that's where the other cameras
cover the things so
double checking everything is is not a
problem because what you see on a plan
and whatever
knowing from personal work experience is
not what you see in real life and so
um just going over
um Barry yeah
[Music]
where is me a wee bit we we're going to
be looking at CR City in Bluff as the
last stages whereas we're getting
vandalism down at uh Sterling Point with
these people Brooke basking both in the
uh hundred thousand dollar glass it's
just why are we going to wait that long
it's a lot of a lot of money and there's
been a lot of damage down
well it always mean that it's third on
the last well it all boils down to the
network as well so the first thing that
we do is the network and the network
that we get that we install is gonna
only allow cameras
and the network will be able to be
expanded
but Leslie are you aware that that
Network how far does it reach well the
intention was that it would it would be
South City Bluff okay so start at the
CBD because that's where the the
subcommittee saw the necessity of the
start and as you say the network cameras
once they're in you can expand
into the areas that were planned to be
covered I think the points that have
been raised are really good and I think
in just a reassurance and another update
um can be brought back and we can just
do it informally on the timeline we've
got here so
um
Darren
they can only install so fast so it's a
case of back in the three years that
because I mean they're all getting done
within three months yep good point
yep fantastic so the recommendation is I
imagine this reports to be received and
we're noting the timeline for December
2023 not it so when we do any PR around
this any comms around what we're decided
on today with that time frame because I
get a lot of feedback from CBD and from
the community patrols as well that
they're
um they're nervous that we we say the
end of the year but then it just keeps
pushing out a little bit pushing out a
little bit and a lot of this is not
necessarily crime rate it's just
people's perception that they feel safe
absolutely we haven't had anything to
say until we made this decision yeah I
know but once we make decisions
or some comms just to tell them hey this
is this is where we're heading
right kind of someone move
um there's two recommendations to move
Darren seconded Evelyn
and put the motion loads in favor
against that is carried that takes us
back to the temporary road closures and
we do have an update on the esk Don
thing stuff yeah um thank you I've
checked with our rating team and all the
closures are for Don Street not East
Street so the correction is needed in my
paper not the application for the formal
road closure my apologies that's okay
right that takes us to that item uh the
temporary road closures who does anyone
want to speak to that
on stock I mean sorry introduced that I
didn't have anything further to add but
can take any questions okay questions
Alan I've obviously I've got one
question as to why the entire block
needs to be closed
for those events because there is um
uh you know there are other public
facilities in the
Kelvin Street end of that particular
block that handles also um a residential
premise here as well so I'm just
wondering why why does the entire block
need to be
closed the road yeah so there's road
closures with traffic management
there'll be as I understand at specific
areas fenced off the residential area
and Don Street will still have access
but you want to open to them only not
just all on Sunday so that's why the
entire block is closed
we've done this before for other events
for example when the Kiln Street party
entitlements used to have events in
there we still had to make sure that
there was access for people to get up to
a pharmacy that was in Don street at the
time so we're not Reinventing the wheel
because you do have a cable Club there
nobody's driving when they're having a
drink Allen are they none of it they're
getting dropped off by their wife some
of them and they can come in of space
Street too can't they
is the cost of the traffic management
um and I think that the last event it
was two and a half thousand dollars for
I mean we had bollards up on them from
what I saw all the traffic management
guy or guys did was put some you know
cones on top of the bollards and then
just seemed to hang around a little bit
um correct me if I'm wrong that seems an
awfully expensive exercise that every
time we put an event on we're gonna
we're gonna have an automatic bill of
two and a half thousand dollars given
that some of these closures are for less
than four hours
is it some consideration that maybe we
might be able to renegotiate or find a
cheaper contractor or do it in-house I
mean I don't know
um I guess to both of those questions
the team within ICC you obviously work
with any
um event organizer to try to come up
with as pragmatic an option as possible
when it comes to
um closures of the roads and and how
much of that extent of Roads needs to be
be closed and they they do you know do a
lot of prompting and a lot of
suggestions around and that's happened
here as well around how things can be
best managed when it comes to the actual
traffic management side of things
um I understand that there was some
significant
um costs associated with the last event
the team have advised back around
different ways that that can be managed
going forward there still needs to be
some traffic management because you're
closing off that access from the other
streets into the street so you do need
to have some set up at the entrance into
the streets
um but agree you don't need to have that
being monitored throughout the closed
Street particularly and ask
um event organizers can put in place a
essentially a standard template traffic
management plan that's approved and then
it's quite a much quicker and less
expensive process to roll that out and
that has been suggested by the team as
well what I'd say is I think this is new
for everybody and we'll make it find
ways I think between both us and um and
events organizers to streamline that as
we um continue to work together okay
thank you uh I've got Evelyn didn't
listen
uh yes Mr cheers so I am going to say
again that I'm quite perturbed that
we've got three events happening in Don
Street
um I do recognize that they are part of
the CBD and they do contribute towards
um inner city activation knowledge all
of those things but I think that
um it seems
that we've turned Don Street into a
two-way street that we're going to keep
on closing down at least once a month
and that does not sit very well with me
um
and I just want my voice to be heard
about that because I think that
um
I think there was an expectation that
when it went back to a two-way street
that it would be
um reasonably accessible all the time
that the limitation would be on East
Street so just putting it there
um the decision will be made
irrespective of what I say or think but
um I am just a little uncomfortable with
three events in a row on Don Street
Aaron do you wanna yeah I can add
something to that I understand
um part of the driver in particular for
the the Food Markets as well was around
if um you were called back to the master
planning work that we did that uh don
Street was around that that very much
food
um based Hub
um now whether or not that's being taken
a little bit too literally I think is
definitely something that we can
um have a discussion with great South
about we were looking at whether or not
we could bring them into this meeting
but timing was just a little bit too
short to do that but absolutely we can
get them to come in and have a
discussion and receive some feedback
from Council around preferences for
events moving forward
Leslie thanks Mr chair actually it's
four events in a row not three oh my bad
because because the FIFA Women's World
Cup is the first to them and then
there's the two food markets and then
there's the street dine so it's four
events in a row um but putting that
aside
um getting back to the road closure
considering that the expected attendance
at these events is a couple of thousand
people with each one I would rather that
we actually had a decent closure of of
the entire section between D Street and
Calvin Street
for safety purposes then
mess around with trying to close a
lesser portion of the street just seems
to me if we're expecting a 2000
attendance
at least initially we should ear on the
side of a road closure that's going to
be as effective as possible for those
numbers
Trish and this is ready for Aaron I
wonder whether you'd pass on to
Charmaine that it was a very successful
night food market held over it next to
outside the church it was particularly
well attended in fact so much so the
food ran out early on it was a lovely um
sort of Ambience or place and just that
she would consider that when you're
thinking about food markets as well
public location yeah it was perfect
Alex
um thank you
um absolutely the one next door was a
roaring success um and I'm actually
personally really excited to see this um
vibrancy in the inner city and some of
our new brand new spaces that we've
invested so much being utilized in
different ways for me personally I don't
see a problem I'm sorry if it's closing
the streets once a month I think that
actually having a reason to be in a city
and bringing people in um and having
that you know I guess sense of something
to do in areas that they haven't hasn't
been done before I think has um
absolutely of benefit to the city and um
I'm glad we're doing something at least
once a month and I hope that we can
maintain that momentum if they want to
close any more streets for public
vibrancy and Community benefit
um
I know well majority of people that I
know that went along to this um would
absolutely be all for it so okay
um before I got the Motions
um question Aaron is that under
Community views it states that have been
to organizers are required to liaise
with affected businesses to minimize
disruption now do we have evidence that
they actually do that I mean it's it's
great that we've got it written there
but but
um do they do we have a checklist or do
we just take it for granted and hope we
we provide instruction around what steps
need to be taken
um in terms of us checking around
whether those steps have been taken we
don't you know we do it at random and
based on based on feedback as opposed to
going out and proactively right so if
there's feedback saying
boy we didn't know about this then
that's how we liaise with our businesses
right okay no that's okay right
um
the recommendations are we receive the
report we resolve the proposed events
outlined will not impede traffic
unreasonably and approve the temporary
road closures as permitted under the
local government to act subject to
receiving a safety
plan for each event that's subject to
receiving it so
we don't have those here
foreign
takes us now to sorry could we just note
that I've stayed oh you abstained
because I might need to sign something
and I actually voted against oh you
voted
Evelyn wants to be recorded record it
takes us to the activities report
I'll be speaking to that one today
although um I'm happy to just take the
reporters read and take me questions
okay tell them
can you cheer um Aaron when I look at
the um stormwater upgrade and D Street
and I I know the comment that there was
a one month delay because of the
archaeological find
um my question is
who makes the decision about you know
how long such a delay would be
acceptable it was a pretty low level as
I understand it pretty little level okay
archaeological find box green a month
seems a long time so we're required to
do that by some other body or did we
elect to delay it by a monster what was
the process
uh there's a couple of pieces that we're
factoring into that one was that
um the timing was definitely not on our
side with regard to that one because
we've come off a period where we used to
have a global consent
um for
heritage-based discoveries
archaeological discoveries and we were
actually this one fell in the period
between that Global consent finishing
and our new process starting so that
left us very much at the um
uh
as as being sort of held up by that new
process was put in place
um
going forward we would hope that we'd be
a little bit more streamlined at that
um but that being said there is
legislative requirements around what we
need to do when we encounter an
archaeological find and we absolutely
have to follow that process
yeah okay through you again sure I hear
that in but did it have to be a month I
mean I I just observed that you know any
UK if you're running a road like that
you make an archaeological find you get
40 errors
to investigate it before you go to
restart so just on one seems
extraordinary so like what I was trying
to get to was whether that month was a
consequence of something that we did or
whether we were absolutely required to
delay by a month
um it was we we didn't just voluntarily
step back we um had several phone
conversations with um all sorts of
different people around what we could do
to
um get things moving forward faster
um but absolutely until we had that
Heritage sign off to start moving again
we we weren't able to move that being
said
um we were still learning through the
process of what we needed to do with
that um now we'd moved off the global
consent
um so there were some things we could
have done better as a council as well
but absolutely we were held up waiting
on that sign off
thank you
further questions on the activities
report
Trish
you're asking difficult questions
new house includes new housing units are
they being started yeah the work the
works on site are currently underway
absolutely
um Lee would have that off the top of
his head um I don't but I can send that
around
yeah it's one of those
um reports that goes through finance and
projects so perhaps not everybody has
visibility of it and we'll look to send
it around
here okay further questions for Aaron
okay that being the case uh there's
three recommendations we received the
report we know the timeline for the D
Street stormwater works and we know the
data Trends across three Waters rating
and housing can I have someone move
those please
uh thank you Alan secondary Grant we'll
put those motion anyone all those in
favor
aye aye against carried thank you that
takes us to the last last item which is
the Strategic approach
okay sorry we've just been advised that
sorry Barry you were a part of the Mover
and second to there we just need to
receive that again
um that item so move Grant second to
Trish well as a favor
right thank you we just uh Barry moved
something earlier on yeah
okay Erin absolutely
um so I apologies for this being a very
large report I guess that what I would
say is
um you can take your time to read as
much of it as you would like or I also
understand if it's a little bit too
detailed focused for for some but we had
some workshops around the long term plan
one of the discussions was around solid
waste and there were some questions
raised on waste minimization as to
whether we would should be making a more
strategic approach in terms of slowing
down and figuring out what our
priorities were or as I saw it also or
alternatively leveraging the Strategic
work that's already being done
nationally and by other authorities and
looking to move forward with some some
quick wins in that respect
um what Annie then did off the back of
that Workshop during the week last week
was pulled together some of the
background strategic information that we
already have to hand to inform that
conversation
Grant yeah um thanks chair I think it's
a really good paper I'd like to see it
put on the resource piece please because
I think it's a great reference point in
from my perspective it gives me
good Clarity around sort of we were
aiming for
um
and so yeah weld under the staff
forgetting it
getting it forward so just in terms of
page 40 a board box yeah waste hierarchy
piece
so those in the next one on 41 that's
the sort of
if we're trying to envisage what we need
to be aiming for around Waste Management
it's those two things that capture it
for me is that a fear yeah Okay cool so
counselors could note those two pages
would be a long way forward
okay Evelyn
already said about
um I can't say that I've read it in
depth because I'm gonna have to go back
and reread it there was a lot in there
but one of the things that struck me was
that
whilst we've been talking about a
long-term plan and this paper has been
provided which is really great but where
are we at talking with some of our other
partners like the likes of the miter 10s
and those who will really pick up some
of those
um
things like light bulbs and
um a garden garden things and all that
you know those bits and pieces
about what they do and how much we can
do together to promote those those
things because I think it would be
really valuable for Community to
actually understand
it comes off the back of what the youth
councilor said this morning too about
people feeling overwhelmed about things
coming at them what can we do well this
is what we can do with batteries this is
what we can do with light bulbs this is
what we can do with their
um you know plant containers or whatever
and these are who our partners are and
actually
um a state of the negative stuff you
know because the negative stuff's really
scary and negative but can we can we
highlight some of the positive things
that are actually happening already that
are making a difference and maybe we
attract some other people who might say
well actually
I could do this
um one of the things that came up was
about paint now there might be an
organization that would be grateful for
half tons of paint for something that
they do within their community group or
whatever so instead of things being
wasted how can we reuse
um or alternatively use where do we find
our partners how do we find them and how
much difference just those little steps
have made
um So within Council and time flies but
within the last few months we employed a
council or a waste net waste
minimization officer
Jackie has been out learning a whole lot
about the new world of waste and
particularly around who we can partner
with in that space in particular miter
10 is one of those organizations that
she's been working with around in
particular their battery disposal and
we're just working through what we need
to do to potentially support that
process that they have in place keeping
in mind that we also need to make sure
that we're covering all of those
wonderful things like health and safety
and and stuff like that
um and we expect to be taking a proposal
on that to the next waste net meeting
um I would guess I would hope that
anybody who is on social media is signed
up to the wastenet Facebook page and
you'll hopefully have seen a little bit
more reinvigorated
um waste net with lots more messaging
um coming through what we're also
looking at is how we can get the message
out to the community Through other
methods other than social media keeping
in mind that from a waste minimization
perspective we don't want to be doing a
mailbox drop
um but just how do we get that that
information out there
knobby
um quite a helpful report but it lacks
some things for me
so given this report the solid waste
Regional report of 2018 which is now
five years since
no mentioning there about the fact that
the city has the recycling contract in
its own right
and we have a supplementary contract
with SDC so somebody coming in new to
council would not know that
um there's no mentioning here that for
the last five years Gore has not done
any recycling at all they just put
everything to landfill
and they're now nine months after the um
last this current term started with a
commitment that we're going to do
something about it and they've done
nothing
and I'm not dumping on them but it just
doesn't give an accurate picture if you
want to do that there's no mention of
the palletizing plant it's
um giving us probably some Cutting Edge
stuff by New Zealand standards and while
the report talks about the ideal world
of educated and been in the speech since
I stopped like that there's no mention
at this stage at the status quo five
years later as we're not doing any of
that I know we're heading towards it but
we're not doing any at the moment so you
could read this report and be really
excited about it all but our actual
stock take on what we're doing at the
moment is pretty poor look I'm gonna
jump in this chair there and also a way
snip remember and I I will totally agree
with the mirror and what is raised is
that States in here in the background
that southland's waste strategy is
driven by uh joint wmmp that's how Waste
minimization Management plan and that
was redone in 2020 and goes to 2026. now
if you read that plan I did that this
morning
um
it opens up by saying that the plan
adopts a holding pattern
and we're we are working to a plan
that's holding now if you're running an
airline you're not going to do very well
um so basically the plan is I see it and
I read through it this morning it's not
for purpose
um so really the question is uh and
including that swap report that Nobby
refers to 2018
um we really need to be working
if we're going to achieve anything
with something that's more current and
purpose Aaron do you want to I mean this
is obviously waste Nets territory but
seriously that wmp is
is just a load of words and and does it
doesn't even mention last separation and
it's it's it's one thing
um I think what I'd say to that is that
those big strategic projects like wmmp
and strategic reviews they do take a lot
of resource and they usually take a lot
of external expertise as well to feed
into
um what we what we currently have at the
moment like at all or not is quite a
generally clear Direction out of central
government around where they want local
authorities to go in this space
um at this stage the discussion at an
officer level within the wastenet
organizations has been to take that
direction and move forward into some
some tangible actions because that's
what we've felt like our councils have
been looking for from us as a little bit
of stop talking about it and start doing
it so that's the feedback that we've
taken on on board
um
there's obviously the opportunity if
invercargill City wants to seek or to go
to waste net and advise they'd like a
different direction in that space then
that that's absolutely icc's prerogative
also well it just says that that we are
driven by this plan
and we have a plan that has no drive so
um I think we've got a problem and
especially with the out the
five-year-old data that we have to work
with is that uh do it does this
committee need to formally a request
that wastenet actually
um does something or how do we do it
because obviously the the difference I
notice that being around this table we
have far more debate we have far more
constructive debate if I go to waste net
and I sit around with the delegates from
Gore and from Southland District
um it's a bit like pulling teeth in fact
to give it an example last Wasteland
meeting I took to them our
recommendation from this Council
requesting funding for a project or
waste minimization funding they're only
just got through the mayor was there
and it was our money to use
but it required both Gore and South and
District to approve us using our money
and really after a half an hour of
debate we only just got it through
um
so I'm just wondering The Way Forward
are we going to get action through waste
net or
this committee seems
um far far more flexible so just want to
ask here and that but I'll
carry on
me to respond to further questions
look what I'd say honestly is from an
officer perspective we seem to be
getting clear Direction out of lacenet
at the moment now I do understand that
that sometimes takes some tussle or
priorities at the political level but
it's probably not holding up stuff at
this point in time
okay right Leslie then Grant then Alex
they know it thank you Mr chair so I've
got no problem at all with the first
recommendation which is receiving the
Strategic approach and I agree some of
the data in it is a bit elderly but the
second one is offering us a choice
in the choice
that we're asking or that staff is
asking us for guidance on is whether
this Council leverages the work of other
authorities around New Zealand to guide
the next steps on air cities waste
minimization Journey or whether we want
a more comprehensive strategic review
it seems to me that a more comprehensive
strategic review is going to hold us up
for 18 months
of
um
review that we probably don't need
because even in the paper we've got it's
Aaron has pointed out there is a very
clear steer
about the sort of things where
being asked or encouraged to deliver
um that
we've expressed around this table on
several occasions that we actually want
to get some movement in a whole host of
waste issues we've got some practical
things that we've discussed that we
could be moving on and I just really
wouldn't like to provide guidance to
staff at this point that says we want to
spend 18 months
um
directing staff to do a strategic review
when we could be getting on with the
Practical stuff that we've discussed
fairly endlessly so I'm I'm actually
quite Keen
that we agree with we could leverage
work from other authorities that we've
already expressed around the table
several ideas that we could make
progress on
and that we probably do want
staff of the city to act on that rather
than
spend a lot of time and staff resource
in a strategic review that to some
extent will tell us what we already know
about the direction government would
like us so so actually yourselves want
to do Leslie raises the point I just
want to interrupt there
um the request for a strategic review
wouldn't actually come from this
committee under the current the way it
works it would come from in your review
would be requested by a wastenet because
it'd be wasting it start doing the
review absolutely so if invercargill
city was a team for that to happen then
it would
um Advocate to wastenet for that to
happen or alternatively invercargill
City can employ somebody to do that
review separately
okay Grant
yeah so I don't know maybe I've got the
wrong end of the stick but
um you know I think we asked for this
paper to give us some sort of idea
around the framework for how we should
be
um well two things one to check in where
we're at currently acknowledging the
fact that what you've raised here around
you know
could be a throwaway comment but it
seems like it's a reasonably
dysfunctional sort of setup in terms of
and the confidence I would have that
wasting it can deliver the outcomes that
we might want as a city there seems to
be again so I think it's imperative that
we at least have a chicken to say
what let's revisit what
we want to achieve from Air waste
mineralization goals is this city
council
and then we that gives us the
opportunity to review can we achieve
that through the current
commercial relationship we have within
wasting it if not then how can we affect
change within that to get those goals
for it city which should be this very
similar to the other stakeholders and
then we stay in that relationship or if
it's too big a get to Bridge and it's
really important for us to go forward as
a city we look at other Alternatives so
the purpose of receiving this
particularly the first report is to
provide that initial let's have a bit of
a workshop around
what does air waste management and
minimalization current strategy look
like
under this framework
where can we make changes can we make
those changes and they be effective
through waste net ASAP so we can get on
with it instead of kicking it around the
table for another eight years
or do we take another course of action
so that's how I said I don't know what
other people think you raise a good
point and for anything to happen is the
trouble is you've got this dual
committee thing you go what you want
here around the table today and then
you've got wasting it and it that's
where the problem arise
um I'll keep going Alex
um thank you
um a few things firstly there is no
misalignment between what everybody
wants the the outcomes are waste
reduction
everybody wants voice reduction
South and what's face reduction Gore
wants waste reduction whether or not
they haven't been actually collecting it
because of political reasons is
irrelevant the fact is everybody wants
waste reduction the wmmp was put in a
holding pattern because we knew that the
government was going to be releasing a
whole lot of information that we would
have to rise to accommodate we now have
that information we've got very clear
steer from the government as to what we
now need to pick up and do
kicking it around the table
and rehashing the wmmp right now when
we've already got a clear direction of
what we need to rise to would actually
just delay the sequence even more
and cost us significant resource to do
so
I honestly think that we should just let
them get on with that we need to get on
with that wastenet needs to get on with
that wait the waste needs to get on with
the delivery for the for the outcomes
that are really clearly outlined in this
report and what they've said that we'll
do we also need to do the same within
and with holding our contracts that we
have with our provider
it's
they've got a job to do which is going
to serve the outcomes that we've asked
for and we've got a job to do that we've
said that we would
so and Nobby yep thank you
um look I'll comment on a few things
here because I've Had The Misfortune I
was sitting in the last two or three way
sniper meetings
um
um look we've got the worst Regional
Waste Management waste minimization
results in the country so that's nothing
to be proud about
um
um this is not a staff issue it's a lack
of leadership from us
um and we're not forceful enough with
our colleagues and the other two
councils Aaron was instrumental in
getting that dollars for
um recycle sales for that eighty
thousand dollars and I sat through that
meeting and she hadn't made the
statement she made we would have been up
the creek without a pedal I don't think
there's a need for a street strategic
review the dysfunction for me sits with
the other two councils I'll give you a
couple of examples so that you
understand I heard people just saying
today things that we could do where you
need to be very careful what we want to
do as a count as a council is not
necessarily what the collective wants to
do I'll give you a couple of examples of
that
I spoke at the last one about the need
to deal to Glass glass is a big issue
for us
um districts said well no we don't go
down that track on glass we we're not
going to do glass collection and bins
we'll just have little wheat been
sitting out around our our rural years
and I understand that when I ask Gore
what their response to Glass was and the
media just looked at the table and
didn't respond
and that's because they're not doing any
recycling so they're not interested in
just isolating glass out of their other
recyclables because it's it's ruining
the contents that they may be able to
resolve and they're just not doing any
at all
and so um
in one Breeze you know we hear Alex
saying look all the stakeholders want to
do waste minimization well that's
actually not what's happening Gore
hasn't done here for five years plus and
even though they've had a mayor come in
that City youth right into all this
stuff nine months down the track he
hasn't done anything and so we're caught
up in that our results are tied up with
our colleagues and so um it's all very
well for us to say well we will just go
ahead and do our own thing and that's
maybe a pathway we go down that track
but why would our rate payers pay for
for item sake for glass recycling when
we've got 700 000 plus sitting in
reserves in waste net which we struggle
to get access to so it's for me it's
still dysfunctional we need to take a
strong lead on it and if we don't get
the ball being played by the Alice we
just need to go alone but we need to get
hold of that money that sits in that
Reserve so that we can fund what we need
to find our rate pay shouldn't be paying
twice
okay look
just to get people straight on the
importance of the waste minimization
plan there's no different to our
long-term plan that we have to comply
with with central government
it's stipulated in the waste
minimization act 2008 and that plan has
to be accurate you can't park it and
have one that says one thing and you
just go and we'll do what the government
tells us that does not work that plan
must align with what council does that's
what it's for so if the plans not
appropriate we we need to fix it because
otherwise we're just breaching our own
directions
that is a critical document
and it needs to be sorted and and if we
don't have that right I can't see how we
can move forward
um
so Alex
actually no
it's not worth it okay so Mr chair are
you advocating for a strategic review
know that any look I think what we need
to ask wastenet is for them to tell us
what their priorities are what's going
to happen in the next one year two years
and we need to as councilors we need to
know that and it needs to come from
wastenet and this Council needs to voice
its opinion that this needs to happen
right now and we want action not talk
so next was Tom and then the airplane so
look I I just think we need another
strategic review no
um I do think that this this I mean West
is
you know it's like a multi-headed beast
doesn't it I mean there's all sorts of
streams that we've got to tackling and I
mean I would just like to see is getting
on a tackle one or two and and there are
obvious targets I mean glasses an
obvious one
yeah um not be useful before about them
a piece of equipment was for plastic
wasn't it and and I don't know where
that one's going but I mean I I I would
rather see us
as I say we can still leave under
wasting it but I mean as a city just
moving ahead and knocking off one or two
of these projects
um I don't think it needs a grand
strategy because it's you know again it
just deletes it for a year at 18 months
so the the plastic one Tom is a pale
sizing plant that basically can take all
classes of plastic with the exception of
bottle tops
pelletism which means that they can be
sold and reused so that minimizes the
impact of single use it's massive if we
get the plant up and running which we
should do it it'll be impacted
Nationwide I mean we will lead the
country in it let's shoot but the other
beauty of it is you if you've seen the
way it's plastic in a bundle
and then you you take that bundle out to
the plant and you pelletize it you
travel the cost of what you get for it
at the other end like it's huge it's a
real money maker I need to carry on here
uh Evelyn then Trish
um so I think if we are following a
national Direction
um
that there's things that we've been
asked to do instructed to do okay this
is possibly a better way of putting it
and it is within our power as a city to
do that
why should we be held back by the fact
that we are also part of wastenet I
don't see the two things as being
mutually exclusive if we can do a better
job in one area then our partner
councils are dying which obviously
every case is different I understand the
difference in
um distances that are involved in the
quantities that are involved from South
and District I totally get that that
does not mean
from my perspective that we should not
do anything about glass
does not mean that we shouldn't do
something about anything that is within
our power to do I think what we're
application and responsibility as
Citizens and as governors of the city
um
sorry
the elected members would be in my view
abrogating their responsibility as
governors of this city if the
opportunity and the drive was there to
do something on behalf of the
environment of the city and we don't do
it because the rest of our partners
aren't there yet
I'm I guess challenging us as a
collective to
um do the hard stuff and just say we're
ready to do it if you're not ready to do
it it's okay because we will put our
money where our mouth is and we'll do it
and be an example okay just just to jump
in there the way waste net is funded
um
by a percentage of the waste that goes
to landfill uh part of the uh 360
including GST tonnage rate uh waste net
claims part of that for every waste
generated out of Southland so it is
funded wastenet gets funded from waste
uh and for us to jump outside that and
that money is used to pay staff and also
build up funding to to do stuff and if
we decide to do as Evelyn said maybe
going alone then we're jumping away from
our shared service agreements and I
would see that
um and just to jump in
uh being on wasted I would say that
that's what I'm saying this committee
talks far more
positively than the debates we have
around wastenet and and it's encouraging
but what I would like to do is to go
back to wastenet and say that this
committee wants action and would like a
list of things that are going to be done
in the next year
and what is happening we don't need the
review I totally agree two can be
scrubbed and we just put a request to
waste net to advise this Council the
things that are going to happen if they
don't then it could come back and we as
Evelyn said we could this council could
just operate on its own and wasting it
ticks all the boxes with shared services
the government looks at it going great
you're all working together
and the unfortunate thing about it
it just doesn't work at a governance
level and and that's that's a bit
unfortunate Trish
Tom's absolutely right we need to get to
knock two or three things off I believe
we cannot wait a year or 18 months for
wasting it to do something I think we
should give them clear direction that
within two months we want them to show
us what they have achieved
give us three three things a week of
them three things we've got done and we
want we review it in two months
and even if they haven't completed what
they want to do if they've actually made
some significant move on that because we
won't get any action if we just keep
wanting them to do it I think we have to
drive it a bit okay look I'm gonna I'm
gonna wind this up now and Trish would
you be happy in in amending that
recommendation too that we just request
what you said and I can come back to
this Council and uh otherwise we'll just
go around circles yeah
um people are happy with that yeah
you're going to have to stipulate what
you said with the purpose of Mala Vega
okay well what we'd like to do then is
uh this committee
um requests wastenet to provide uh
within two months uh a strategic
um the plan for the next
two years
actions sorry actions what actions
specific work
um report a bit to us what they're going
to do very shortly not for 17 months and
then within two months achieve that and
come back to us or work towards
achieving that
look
sorry Leslie yeah
I don't think that is going to achieve
at all what we're talking about I think
it will just add to a time delay where
we don't get to do anything
um and it still becomes a bit of a talk
Fest because we know on the priorities
we've identified like the glass
recycling that both South and district
and Gore have indicated they're not at
the same stage as us I don't think that
we've got a choice of going it alone and
sort of pulling out a waste knit
we can stay as part of wastenet
but suggest to wastenet that we are able
to commence as the city on something
like the glass recycling initiative
which southern district and Gore could
come into at a later stage so glass
recycling for us
we could progress
not by pulling out a waste net or saying
we're going it alone but saying to
wastenet we would be the first adopter
unfortunately we cannot progress unless
we get the buy-in and the formal
authorization and just to give you the
idea about the small amount we requested
the other day that was hard enough let
alone putting forward any other requests
so that's what I'm saying like like
Thomas said
for glass recycling it's exactly yeah
Tom and I are on the same page I'll just
interrupt Aaron
um so
I'm just consciously maybe getting a
little bit ahead of ourselves on this
one
um I know that there's been discussions
perhaps politically around what
different council's views are at the
moment but at this stage the staff
report has not gone to waste net which
would be prepared by my team to go to
them to say here are the costs
associated with glass out here are your
different options for whether or not one
Council does that two councils do that
three councils do that
um and for I guess all of the partner
councils to have that information in
front of them and make a decision
based off that piece of work we may find
that we don't have a problem and all
three councils actually want to go in or
we may find that one or two councils
don't want to go in and that doesn't
necessarily mean that we can't go ahead
with it because as was given the example
at the moment we actually have different
service provision across the different
councils at the moment which we see with
Gore not providing the same Services as
the other two two councils do
that would be to me a more positive way
of going back to waste net if we are
staff here and leading it obviously to
produce a paper that went to waste net
that set out what you've just advised
okay and that replaces two that could
replace two definitely um and and if we
paused for a few minutes we could
probably work on some wording that
encompassed what everybody was coming a
hand over to knobby yeah just one thing
to be mindful of
we could put up a party on glass that's
our number one issue at the moment
pelletizing plant will take take what it
takes so the issue is not the fact that
Gore's doing nothing the issue is we
need to do something about our glass it
ruins our recycling process so we could
put up something saying that we want
glass to be resolved and resolve quickly
if the other two councils don't want to
go down that pathway yet they're not
ready for it or don't want to go down
the pathway we want to go down that's
fine too as as I said but the stumbling
blockers we've got to have the money to
do what we need to do and at the moment
those money that money is tied up and
waiting it our shares about 700 000
sitting there in reserves and we've got
to get the approval of the other two so
part of the paper that needs to go to
say we want to resolve glass if you
don't want to go on the journey you've
got to release our share of that Reserve
so that we can go on the journey that's
where we came to last time with the 80
000 yeah it could include costs
which might make it then easier for the
other two councils to agree that that
would be productive
some money could be released sure so it
seems more productive too so just to
give you an update on the glass the
process forward of that is that the the
options that we're gonna consult the
public on are going to be done they have
to be done during the ltp there is no
shortcut unfortunately I've talked this
through with staff and and it has to be
done but it doesn't mean that that that
we it it's that the funding issues Nobby
talked about we can't have those sorted
in advance by requesting
um because we haven't done that yet but
but the process has to go through the
ltp so if we don't have that in advance
the funding agreement to come out of
wasting it when we go to consult with
the public that'll hit rates correct
yeah it's crazy
yeah and the other thing is procurement
the other issue we have is is
procurement issues of bins and we just
need to start working on that as well
because we can't pre-empt something for
the for our ltp
um
but there would be nothing to stop us
putting forward such a staff paper to
waste net that at least got in it is
that okay yeah so absolutely so we're
working through that at the moment we
have initial prices from Bond I just
need to go back and ask some further
questions for us to be able to form that
up we won't be going to the next meeting
of wastenet which is in about 10 days
time it will go to the following month
okay
um do you have something for us we're
just about to type it up just about to
type it up so in the meantime we're
going to go Alex then Barry
um
I just want to wrap up a little bit of
what that last statement was
um you you're right that if we were to
go It Alone individually and request
wastenet to dip into those reserves
um that wouldn't potentially be for the
initial I don't know
um containers for glass or whatever it
is the result of our investigation would
be but if it was a if it was a general
capex lift and then a new contract then
that would be something that we would
have to absorb individually without the
other Council so there would be that
would be either be a rates rise because
we're upgrading our levels of service
and that's not part of the shared
service that's a rate that's a that's an
us decision not a collective benefit
decision
um so there could be potential rates
rises in there if we do decide to go
down that track
so can I just can I reflect on that
please uh yeah through your chair
um
but again if we've got 700 000 sitting
in reserves at the moment with lace net
if we can't get partner agreement for us
to do what we need to do regardless of
whether they want to do it then that's
that money's just Frozen a good example
was the 80 000 for the palletizing plant
that both buried and rainy talked about
before
it was like pulling hands teeth and
thinking to Aaron for getting us over
the line on that
um but the issue was they weren't
prepared to commit to that palletizing
plant upgrade but it's really
interesting I said well that's okay
we'll fund it we'll get the credit for
it nationally oh hang on no no we don't
want you saying it's an invercargill
credit we want to get some spin out of
this as well I said well if you want to
get some spin out of it you got to free
up the money you can't have a penny both
ways on this issue
so
um can I carry on uh sorry yeah
um I appreciate that your worship um but
if it isn't if it isn't got an ongoing
year-on-year glass recyclables
collection
or you know like that's going to be a
year on year
Opex cost rather than just a one-off
reserves cost we're going to have to
fund it somehow for sure
um yeah and I think it is like I I get
really uncomfortable when I hear some of
the comments being thrown around the
room
um about wastenet being this big old
scary situation where they're all just
dominating us and won't let us do what
we want with our money because and it's
our money and it's like pulling hens
teeth because it was really important to
check the history on that situation that
before
there was tension or political
dysfunction with wastenet it was touted
as the poster child The Golden Child
example of how a joint venture
um also a joint Services can agreements
can work together and work really and
work in synchronicity everyone it was
you know worked really well together for
many years until we became the problem
and we politically pulled out of a
unanimous decision so it's it's I get
really uncomfortable when the people sit
in the room and throw around all of
these things about about our regional
partners that we work together with on
many other things not just wastenet
they're the same people they're the same
councils they're the same officers doing
really good work for us and it all kind
of just gets
swept under the carpet sometimes because
of the political environment
so I just really really wanted to
clarify that too thank you okay well I
guess I can't let that one go as cheer
being on wasting it since 2010
um I think poster child is probably an
exaggeration in fact I was booted off
wastenet by the committee in 2019 for
speaking my mind about what invercargill
needed to do
so if anyone thinks that wastenet really
is interested in invercargill they need
to take another thought that's my
opinion on it and I've probably know
more about wasting it than anyone here
in this room
so we have Ria finally sorry about that
I'm okay sorry I forgot what I was going
to ask you after all of us
so we have something new
uh right we have a request staff to
repair and present a report to wastenet
on glass recycling with options for one
two or three councils in the Pimlico
city council choose to proceed by
themselves the relevant funds would be
released from less than and there would
be opic Scots but they are based on
rates the funds would be used to
subsidize the initial purchase of bins
if that is what the lqp comes out is
sorry
can I have someone move Greer
would like to move those three uh
seconded Tom two oh sorry we gotta
sorry a proper glasses on
two
recommendations
Tom seconded I'll put that all those in
favor
aye against okay and I'd like to thank
the committee for the debate on this
because it's a serious matter and as I
said before
um it's great to show the interest can I
just check that staff are comfortable
that we've given enough direction for
the current time thank you absolutely
someone please move we're going to
public excluded because we're going to
talk about some secret scrum stuff so
I'll move
the emotional as a favor